and I think the narrative the media ran
with it like DJ's final fight I'm like I
haven't heard him say that you know
where that narrative came from I mean it
could be my last fight right like you
said you you're an athlete you've fought
before you I'm sure you've had these
feelings come arise in your training
camp when you're getting for your next
your next fight and for me you know I'm
human these are my emotions that I feel
when when is it time to call it when do
you walk away from the sport something I
never you know charted on before right
I've had these feelings before but I've
never actually expressed them to the
public and talk about it for me yeah I
could buy one at the time 40. I'm
healthy I'm still fast way is great I
love dieting I love training I love
competing but that has some important
time where the the athletes take a step
back I'm okay your brand is Big you've
pretty much accomplished everything in
mixed martial arts you can't buy forever
so when are you gonna make that step to
start focusing on other things outside
of the next emotional Arts